18 menschen alle leben in deutschland
unser experiment findet in einem großen
studio mit ausreichend abstand stadt
schutzmasken nicht nötig was genau
passieren wird wissen die teilnehmer
noch nicht hadija haruna ist seit jahren
aktiv in der rassismus forschung bis zur
nächsten linie vertreten dürfen
diejenigen auf die die folgenden
aussagen zu treffen ich kann davon
ausgehen die gleichen beruflichen
chancen zu haben wie kolleginnen und
kollegen mit vergleichbarer
qualifikation
[Musik]
ich kann davon ausgehen dass man mir bei
behördengängen wie zb zum jobcenter oder
dem standesamt ohne vorbehalte begegnet
[Musik]
ich kann in der regel davon ausgehen in
schule ausbildung und beruf aufgrund
meiner herkunft oder meines aussehens
nicht benachteiligt zu werden
ich habe in der schule schon bilder
erfahrungen gemacht relativ früh schon
in der grundschule damals wurde so ein
film ausgestrahlt r hießen
schornsteinfeger dieser titel und
natürlich fanden die jugendlichen das
damals ganz toll mehr hinterher zu rufen
und zu lachen und dann mit dem finger
auf mich zu zeigen
diese frage ist kurz und knapp ich kann
unbesorgt in alle regionen deutschlands
ein
[Musik]
ich habe schon die freiheit über den zu
reisen aber ich habe dann auch nicht die
lust an orte zu reisen wo ich dann
schlechtere erfahrungen machen muss
wegen meines aussehens dann macht es mir
auch den urlaub kaputt dann gehe ich
lieber nicht denn dann bleibe ich lieber
dort wo ich wenigstens einschätzen kann
die leute mit mir umgehen
ich fühle mich aufgrund meiner religion
oder der mir vermeintlich
zugeschriebenen religion nicht
benachteiligt
[Musik]
ich kann mir sicher sein dass meine
hautfarbe meine herkunft oder mein name
bei der wohnungssuche keine rolle
spielen
[Musik]
wenn ich mich als deutsche oder als
deutscher bezeichnen kann ich davon
ausgehen dass das für mein gegenüber
selbstverständliche
alle fragen sind beantwortet
ihr habt eure position gefunden könnt
ihr euch nochmal umdrehen die die vorne
stehen und die die hinten sie nach vorne
und gucken was für ein bild jetzt
entstanden ist
[Musik]
was mich jetzt bewegt ist das ergebnis
dass einige ganz am rand gewinnen sind
tut mir einfach weh
ja es ist natürlich jetzt eine brutale
gegenüberstellung finde ich und man hat
ein bisschen schlechtes gewissen also
mein leben ist einfach so also seitdem
seit ich hier bin also in berlin
[Musik]
es ist schon so ein schlag ins gesicht
da nochmal immer stehen zu bleiben
werden andere halt dann immer weiter
gehen und dann an sie sind irgendwo am
ziele man steht aber noch am start
ich bin deutscher und das ist also und
ich würde halt gerne akzeptiert werden
und die stände gerne doch lieber mit
weiter vorne als wir hinten aber ich
kenne es halt nicht anders
es ist für mich relativ normal und bei
mir ist jetzt die leiterin dieses
experiment sie ist politologin sie ist
journalistin sie ist rassismus expertin
herzlich willkommen hadija haruna ärger
schön dass sie da sind hat sie bei dem
experiment irgendwas überrascht
nein es genau so gelaufen wie es hätte
laufen sollen
menschen die in privilegierten
situationen sind kommen ganz nach vorne
und die die nicht haben die bleiben
zurück so wie in der realität halt auch
wie schafft man ist weil alle waren ja
hinterher doch betroffen
und vor allen dingen man will ja auch
nicht als opfer dastehen also auch wenn
man ganz hinten steht man will ja gar
nicht opfer sein
wie schafft man es also denen auch dann
das gefühl zu geben wir wollen
aufmerksamkeit schaffen ohne euch
fortzuführen das ist eigentlich ganz
schwierig weil alle lassen sich darauf
ein und es kommt auf die gruppe an also
auch in dieser gruppe ist natürlich ein
raum entstanden
das war so ein geben und nehmen und dann
passiert was wenn man sich zusammen
beschäftigt miteinander und einander
zuhört darum geht es ja im endeffekt und
es geht natürlich auch gerade jetzt in
der aktuellen diskussion darum zuzuhören
zu lernen und da sagen dann viele ja wir
brauchen auch beispiele wie wiso und
wandern eigentlich genau
sie sagen sie sind übrigens in
deutschland geboren ihr vater kommt aus
ghana ihre mutter ist deutsche
und sie sagen ich kann es nicht mehr
hören das ist für mich rassismus porno
die balance dazwischen sehen sie aber
dass man an der einen oder anderen
stelle beispiele braucht die sich schon
jetzt kann man aber sagen wir hatten
schon unzählige diskussionen über
rassismus werden unterschiedliche
hashtags schau hin me too man könnte
jetzt auch sagen wir haben wirklich
genug in den letzten jahren darüber
geredet also die die von rassismus
betroffen sind haben das auf jeden fall
und haben deswegen dieses mal gesagt wir
wollen wir einen schritt weiter gehen
lasst uns jetzt mal tacheles reden und
wasser
im besten fall und das schöne ist ja im
moment gerade auch durch die anti
schwarzen debatte ist viel ausgelöst
worden ich glaube dass menschen mit
einer weißen oder hellen hautfarbe zum
ersten mal überhaupt realisiert habe
stimmt ich bin ja weiß also wenn man
sich vorher nie darüber gedanken gemacht
hat also man sieht das privilegierte und
wie gesagt menschen sind sensibel wollen
zuhören wollen aber auch nachfragen und
es gibt ein paar die in dem diskurs sind
aus der schwarzen community sein
ich hab kein bock mehr drauf ich bin
wütend ich will auch nichts mehr
erklären jetzt ist halt ein buch oder
macht irgendwas wie schafft man es die
wu zwar zu äußern aber gleichzeitig den
fragen nämlich permanent dann auch vor
den kopf zu stoßen weil er ja vielleicht
lernen möchte ich glaube es kommt
einfach auf empathie an dass es gibt
einfach viele menschen haben sich den
mund fusselig geredet und den sollte man
auch zu rechnen oder akzeptieren dass
die vielleicht nicht mehr reden möchten
und das ist tatsächlich genug material
gibt aber natürlich gibt es auch andere
die sind noch bereit zu sprechen die
bieten kurse an ge haben ja hier auch so
einen wie auch ja zum beispiel aber die
an die sich zu halten und zu sagen okay
wir sind offen weil jetzt sind wir mal
dran das ist ja auch ein teil dieses
privilegien dings zu erkennen
ich muss vorsichtig sein es geht nicht
immer nur um mich und wenn ich jetzt
traurig bin und weine weil ich dinge
erkennen
dann ist es gut aber dabei sollte es
nicht bleiben dann innerhalb die frauen
im bh die hat das total berührt und
gleichzeitig gibt es ein konzept das
nimmt sich white tea ist im sinne von es
darf nicht bei tränen bleiben dir deine
konsequenz es geht nicht um dich
persönlich das ist ein großes system
rassismus ist ein gesellschaftliches
system wenn du das also jetzt verstehst
dann nutze das privileg und ändere etwas
es gibt wenn wir schon bei sprache sind
eine frage die immer sofort jedenfalls
im moment zum diskurs führt und die
lautet wo kommst du her
ich will ehrlich sein ich stehe sie
einfach aufheben aus interesse aus
neugierde aus offenheit weil ich weiß
dann irgendwann erzähle ich auch über
die wurzeln meiner eltern und so und da
gibt es auch einige die sehr empfindlich
auf diese frage reagieren und sagen auf
gar keinen fall als rassistisch ich will
diese frage nicht mehr
und dann muss auch persönlich muss ich
sagen da
nicht immer ein bisschen schockiert weil
man denkt es kommt doch auf den ton an
auf die haltung auf die intention und
nicht wenn ich spüre dass mein gegenüber
dann sagt du kannst unmöglich deutsch
sein und deswegen stelle ich dir die
frage dann breche ich auch habe aber
wenn mir jemand aus interesse die frage
stellt ja dass die intension man könnte
jetzt auch sagen die intension ist mir
doch egal wenn ich alle fünf minuten
diese frage gestellt bekommen und wenn
ich an jedem rad neue menschen
kennenlernen und ich bekommen sie in den
ersten zwei minuten gestellt wenn kleine
kinder im kindergarten gefragt werden wo
kommst du her oder dann im pädagogisch
wertvoller gedacht kommen deine eltern
her
diese permanente fremd verordnung mit
der man aufwächst ist natürlich
bezeichnet ist einfach so eine plakative
frage oder ein plakatives beispiel für
ein system dahinter
das heißt politisch bewusste menschen
oder die sich mit ihrer eigenen
identität sage ich jetzt mal
auseinandersetzen werden mit dieser
frage immer etwas anderes verbinden aber
es geht nicht um diesen einzelfall wenn
wir jetzt länger uns unterhalten haben
und schon ganz viel ausgetauscht haben
und ich auch ganz viel von ihnen weiß
dann kann man natürlich darüber reden
die frage ist ja der blick darauf hier
in deutschland hat herkunft einfach auch
eine ist negativ besetzt wenn man aus
bestimmten ländern kommt dann ist das
nicht dann wird das nicht als hoher wert
angesehen sondern als da sind dann die
ganzen rassistischen stereotypen auch
dahinter dass die junge frau im film
sagt ich bin deutsche sie ist der
schwarze deutsche ihr wird das permanent
abgesprochen sie hat keine lust mehr
darauf gefragt sind wer also kommt so
auf das wan und auch auf das warum und
in jedem individuellen einzelfall
es gibt menschen die haben kein problem
und andere haben ein doppelt so großes
und bleiben wir bei sprache wir haben
das n wort das die abkürzung gepiepse
ich glaube war das ein wort müssen wir
nicht diskutieren ist auch dass ich
nicht mehr aussprechen
klar aber dann gibt es eben auch die
design und ich dafür überhaupt nichts
mehr sagen jetzt da hab ich nicht mehr
machen kopf sagen jetzt habe ich nicht
mehr zigeunerschnitzel sagen und und
objekte so und ich weiß nicht warum was
sagen sie den also abgesehen davon dass
diese anderen wörter auch nicht sagen
damit man versteht auch hier also
sprache ist für mich ein moment in dem
man sich mit rassismus auseinandersetzt
weil sie so nah wir alle sprechen sprach
und wir haben uns vielleicht mit der
geschichte der sprache nicht beschäftigt
und in der geschichte der sprache steckt
aber eine rassistische vorgeschichte
weiß der kolonialismus der holocaust
sinti und roma
wurden ermordet im zweiten weltkrieg ab
oder er muss heißt dieser völkermord und
dieses wort beispielsweise für sinti und
roma ist an diesem ort gekoppelt dass
diese menschen spüren ist von innen
heraus genau wie beim antwort das kann
sich ein mensch der diese geschichte
nicht über generationen in sich trägt
nicht vorstellen und gleichzeitig sagen
sie aber auch ganz oft ich lass ihn ja
ihre kindheit und die erinnerungen daran
dass ich ganz wichtig und fand es
wirklich interessant und sagen aber auch
natürlich haben wir uns weiterentwickelt
als ja das ist doch das ist der
wichtigste punkt sich mal zu lösen von
der eigenen biografie zu sagen als kind
war das vollkommen in ordnung weil da
war auch rassismus in dem wissen von
salonfähig da haben alle so gesprochen
aber heute ist heute heute sitzen mehr
leute am tisch wir sind alle wenn wir
eine gleichwertige gesellschaft sein
wollen dann müssen wir einander zuhören
und dann sind vielleicht dinge die
früher okay waren heute nicht mehr okay
also wir haben über sprache gesprochen
die beeinflusst die kann strukturen
schaffen natürlich die er fördert in
teilen aber auch den institutionellen
strukturellen rassismus was fordern sie
da was glauben sie was braucht es jetzt
um wirklich veränderungen herbeizuführen
also für mich ist das so eine art
dreisatz also es braucht definitiv
aufklärung es braucht aufarbeitung ist
braucht forschung und es braucht eine
strukturelle veränderung und
aufarbeitung ist tatsächlich etwas
rassismus kritische bildung und damit
meine ich nicht nur schule ich meine die
medien ich meine ich meine institution
ich meine alle lehrkräfte in
bildungsbereichen rassismus kritische
bildung alleine dieses wort in den mund
zu nehmen fällt ja manchen schon schwer
was bedeutet dass das bedeutet alle
curricula alle dinge noch mal umzudrehen
zugucken wie alt ist das zeug was steht
da drin welche bilder werden präsentiert
und dann zu sagen wir brauchen forschung
es gibt zb den afro zensus der ja gerade
erhoben wird
wir haben vorhin viel überzahl gehört
wenn wir keine zahlen haben dann können
immer leute sagen auch dann nur
einzelfälle also das leben schwarzer
menschen wird jetzt also von der
community selbst erforscht und
verhindern wir haben so viel über
behörden gesprochen als ein beispiel
behörden also ist wenn man behördlich
etwas verändern soll ich würde jetzt
einfach mal den begriffen nehmen auch
die polizei braucht eine dekolonisierung
denn die polizei geschichte hat auch
eine koloniale
vorgeschichte auch in deutschland die
kritische polizei wissenschaft forscht
dazu das sogenannte polizei es gibt so
viel zu wissen und es machen professoren
hier auch an der an den polizei
hochschulen auch da also es gibt die
strukturen ändern bedeutet sie erst mal
anzuschauen wir brauchen zahlen
und wir brauchen den willen dazu und
dieser geschichte zu stellen und wir
haben viel aus unserer geschichte
einfach noch nicht verarbeitet ich
könnte noch zwei stunden mit ihnen
weiter sprechen das ist wirklich
wahnsinnig interessant ich bedanke mich
ganz ausdrücklich auch für ihren besuch
heute hadija haruna älter und ich glaube
was man mitnehmen kann ist vor allen
dingen erst mal auch reflektieren auch
sich selbst auch wenn man denkt man sei
aufgeklärt verletzungen des gegenübers
vor allen dingen auch anerkennen lernen
sich weiterentwickeln
unsere wäre es heute auch gemacht haben
fragen nachfragen mit einer offenheit im
dialog bleiben und vor allen dingen was
sie auch gesagt haben richtigerweise ist
handeln denn gequatscht wurde schon sehr
viel und jetzt muss einfach auch was
passieren